après Noël les en attendant les soldes
divers dans quelques jours une grande
vente éphémère a lieu en ce moment et
jusqu'à samedi au Centre Commercial leur
tranquille à Tours les baskets et
vêtements de grandes marques à prix
cassé des invendus la saison dernière
succès garanti comme a pu le constater
Faustine une
file d'attente s'allonge dans l'allée de
leur tranquille l'appel aux bonnes
affaires a attiré la foule alors
l'entrée dans ce magasin se fait au
compte-goutte je suis étonné de la queue
en fait je m'attendais pas à ça on a vu
sur Facebook qui allait y avoir des
réductions au niveau des des chaussures
de sport
du coup vous cherchez une des bonnes
affaires bien sûr il faut en profiter si
c'est possible le hangar une boutique
éphémère itinérante dans toute la France
a fait escale pour la première fois à
Tours à l'intérieur des milliers
d'invendus des saisons précédentes
principalement des baskets et des
vêtements de marque récupérer par
l'enseigne et revendu moins cher
un concept qui attire la clientèle même
s'il faut prendre le temps de fouiller
on a trouvé pas mal de choses alors qu'à
la base on est vraiment pour qu'une
paire de chaussures c'est vrai qu'on
trouve vraiment de bonnes affaires et
notamment pour les enfants surtout qui
grandissent vite et on a vraiment besoin
de vêtements par exemple sur une veste
10 euros la petite veste ça vaut
vraiment le coup deux paires de
chaussures de sport pour moi et deux
paires de chaussures de sport pour ma
chérie
c'est des bonnes affaires
moyen mais oui le seul souci c'est le
rangement c'est un peu bordelique chacun
met n'importe comment autrement c'est
sympa dernier passage par la caisse pour
régler ses achats la boutique reste
ouverte jusqu'au 7 janvier